4e sur l 4 sur elle les pelles à de
bardet d'un groupe improbable nom
masculin qui curieusement a réussi à
briller dans un domaine qui n'a rien à
voir avec la cuisine
je vous entends une fois diplômés elles
ont déployé leurs selles et tente de
prendre leur envol et délices pavail
arômes spécial bourges en espérant ne
pas s'écraser même si on s'y attend un
peu je m'éclate vraiment dans ce que je
fais là je vise l'école vétérinaire
je croise les doigts où en sont là
aujourd'hui je m'appelle et me lavallée
winehouse à aller en balance son j'ai
plaqué mon boulot j'ai vu mon nom j'ai
démissionné et on va bien tout
simplement je serai prête à tout pour
rechanter avec vous à tous les filles
tous les ans un concert est organisé
pour soutenir les troupes en europe
et si j'arrivais à nous incruster ouais
il se trouve que là j'ai plein de temps
libre alain
ah ouais grave
[Musique]
mais on sait jamais mesuré à des groupes
qui avaient des instruments alors c'est
quoi le plan
des randonneurs en fait vous reprenez
des chansons genre karaoké car c'est
trop mignon
je suis calamité voici sérénité véracité
et charité et moi si j'ai entré dans le
groupe pourrait être obésité
nouvelle journée sur scène et les baies
la touche le fond ah oui elles
s'entendent mais on est bien sûr puis tu
déjà lâché ah oui plein de fois quoi
c'est pas du tout fiable c'est disons
que c'est dans ta nature tu te rappelles
pas toutes les fois où j'ai assuré à
mort
[Musique]
passons à la carte un fouet
vous m mambé tordu
[Musique]
tâcher de garder un peu de dignité
ouais mais nous ont fait part dans la
dignité
tu vois il devient urgent qu'elle entre
dans la vie active
ah oui